good morning Hank it's Sunday it's
Newsday I'm coming to you from a room
that will hopefully someday be my
bathroom but it's currently just another
uninhabitable room in my house so Hank
in your last couple videos which by the
way have been great you've been talking
about why we think about the things we
think about and why we behave the way we
behave and how sometimes we're incentive
eyes by corporations to act like jerks I
want to continue that conversation a
little bit so the other day the Yeti
comes home from work and I'm crying and
she's like what he cried about pansy and
I was like there's this boy in Colorado
and he's not in a balloon he's in his
attic he's safe now maybe you may be
thinking given that you could choose to
think about anything in the world why on
earth would you think about a flying
saucer balloon flying over Colorado and
I'll tell you why I was thinking about
it because I could root for something I
didn't have to think about the
complexities of tribalism in Afghanistan
or healthcare policy there was a boy in
a balloon and I wanted him to live but
as is usually the case with stories that
make sense it turned out not to make any
sense at all so hey what happened was
this kid Falcon Heene although the
newscasters couldn't figure out how to
pronounce his last name so for the
longest time they were calling him
Falcon honey I'm just gonna call him
Falcon heinie so the hiney family is
into science and you know science
families have balloons and stuff so
six-year-old Falcon heinie climbs into
this balloon the balloon takes off and
then he is in what balloonist referred
to as mortal danger then after hours the
balloon starts to descend this hero
grabs a guide wire and it's like dragged
along by the balloon for the longest
time then pulls it to the ground and
then there's no kid in the balloon so
the question becomes where is Falcon by
the way that's about when I started
crying but then a story started to get a
little weird
turns out the family's been on the show
wife swapped twice and that they aren't
into science as such they're into weird
science and not the kind of weird
science where you make hot girls but the
kind of weird science where you think
that Hillary Clinton is a reptilian
seriously Hank the dad of this family
thinks that Hillary Clinton is something
called a reptilian which is where
like a reptilian nature but you're able
to do shape-shifting and he also thinks
that a secret cabal of these
shape-shifting reptilians runs the world
now I know in comments I'm gonna get a
lot of joints widget banger who are like
don't make fun of reptilians they'll
come for you but I'm just going to come
out and say attack believing that there
is a secret cabal reptilian
shapeshifters who run the world is
stupid so a few hours later they find
Falcon heinie hiding in a box in his
attic and the Sheriff's Department
assures us that it could not have been a
hoax but it turns out it was a hoax and
the sheriff is going to be finding
charges against mr. heinie within the
next few days now I don't know what
hooks evidence the police have but let
me tell you when I know it was a hoax it
wasn't when Falcon heinie turned to his
dad and said you said we did this for a
show or even the next day when Falcon
heinie was forced to go on The Today
Show and vomited because who can blame
him for that I mean I vomit sometimes
just watching The Today Show I knew it
was a hoax when Daddy Heine said I'm not
selling anything this is what we do all
the time this is what we do all the time
he said and look how many people watched
it and wouldn't that make great
television he got on white-swathed twice
he pitched his show to TLC that they
passed on but he couldn't stop wanting
to be a famous television star Hank so
he faked the possible death of his son
and he thought he would get away with it
because like all narcissists he thinks
that he's a genius and Hank
nerdfighters here is my non-rhetorical
question of the day for you given what
we know about Fame given that we know it
leads to divorce and borderline
personality disorder and shaving your
head for no reason and general ass Henry
why do people want to be famous and more
disturbingly why will they sell out
their values and the people they love in
order to get attention from strangers by
the way I'm not casting aspersions on
others I think that everyone struggles
with this including me but I just don't
get it if we behave in the way we're
incentivized to behave what
the possible incentive for fame it's not
money lawyer to make better money than
the stars of TLC shows what is it Hank
you'll see me on Tuesday